I'm not well
I am NOT well if I was well I would not
do right now nope still don't feel well
what I said before I forgot what I was
saying forget to off everyone's insane
yeah I don't I feel it doesn't matter
just this what sometimes when you're an
adult and you have adult beverages you
should not have very many not especially
I'd like no the problem is with the
problem for the casino I don't want to
talk about the casino I'd better crack
about anything you know we shouldn't
take away what snapchat brienne yeah
this girl like honestly it's really a
shame that she has a super secret snuff
no no one yep you think it's a good
thing freeze snapchat prettiest outside
we're gonna go side now I just woke up
took a nice nap because hey we're also
do buy a hat I've got to get you
chapstick ss it's got good because my
lips are trapped may I have some oh okay
you're like you're inside here's the Hat
that's the one I wanted yo hey Mike with
all this one let me see what you look
like but you wanted a super let me see
what you look like what's your name
I look like a total I'm oh I look like
totally yeah
do I look like toad I feel like us - why
eat why would you put your hands on a
tree we did this it is nice actually
it's the same it's the same hat yeah
turning back is your happy is my not
fighting minds here this isn't the only
thing I want because I had three how
much we don't know somewhere else I
think I think so I don't want to spend
$20 on state wakes it up I don't know I
will look at you
I won't look at you because I don't feel
a little kinky Mary's open hats here we
are again do that again play a new whole
act again well her original reaction was
better I try to capture it again that
looks you look like wait I don't know
you really Kim Kardashian there you go
looks good yeah I love me yeah I don't
think that's I got media like that's 200
no no we get ahead you know me have to
get outside do the math divide it 20
divided by 2 times my 10 we came back to
acquire but the hats because we could
all share that
I am NOT Beyonce
well today's days ending these kids are
making me go to the casino I'm very
upset because I am NOT well oh I'm not
I'm still not good I want to show them
my outfit though Casino where I hope the
casino likes it it looks like you're
wearing jeans yeah
when you think about fashion this is the
first thing that you think about it when
I think I'll actually think about what
it's like to be beautiful and this is
beautiful but caught these pants are
awesome
let me give you a little peek of the
punch hold on let me show you who died
it looks like you pooped I couldn't
figure wearing a diaper
what is the title of today's video Saget
in the Quran cuz I'm not well I'm not
well Saget in the crotch someone's agony
crotch
what's your money in it gotcha stuff way
under these pockets real yeah would you
put a vintage somebody in there oh she's
going out like when you try to like like
pick up a pig only dude was like grab
her neck like how do I remove this we
kept pushing microsurgery what is the
plan broke loose instant death I'll see
you tomorrow
hey Bri doesn't thing what is tell that
consumption freak was from your credit
dead I'm scared I told me service
healthy at all there's probably lots of
plaque there who wants to eat healthy
won't keep on working on it go so no
you're not